it's great to be joined today by Marcelo
gleiser who's a theoretical physicist
author and NPR commentator his
scientific research centers around
origins of the universe of matter and of
life his books traced the history of
science within a cultural religious and
philosophical context than his most
recent books are the island of knowledge
and the simple beauty of the unexpected
Marcelo it's so great to speak to you
today I'd like to start with the idea of
the concept of reality as as something
that we can think about objectively how
far back do do human considerations of
what is real go well you know that's
already a pretty heavy loaded question
right because the idea of reality is
very elusive and and different times and
people thought about it in different
ways and so if you want to go really way
back right I mean I would say that the
first time in our history as humans that
we start to contemplate the notion of
reality was when we're still in the
caves and we started to represent some
of what was going on you know both as
hunters or as worshipers of nature right
because at that time nature was divine
in a sense everything was a god you know
the volcano God the tree God in caves
right so they would represent their
perception of reality on cave walls with
their paintings and I think that is the
first time where I think the thicker
cortex so to speak of humans started to
give out something which was a
contemplation of the meaning of being in
the world and of representing that world
through an image so I'll put it that
back you know at least what are some of
the more notable ways in which the human
understanding of reality has changed
from from those moments through today
and feel free to be general or if there
are specific moments in human history
that a fundamental
we altered our understanding of reality
by all means feel free to tell us about
those sure so you know let's first let's
qualify things a little bit because we
at least you know we tend to think a lot
in western terms right and people have
been dealing with the notion of reality
in eastern civilizations for a very long
time as well so I would say that the
first point is when people realize that
nature was much more powerful than they
were and that there are forces about the
natural world that they could not
control so one interpretation of the
origin of religion in general is to say
that it was an attempt to try to gain
some kind of control over a reality
which was well beyond human
understanding right so by by saying that
there is a volcano God for example right
and by worshipping that God and by
having rituals to serve that God what
people were trying to do is develop some
kind of language where they could
actually black hate or make the God
happier so that the volcano would not
erupt and destroy their village so to
speak so there was an attempt at a
communication with something that is
beyond the human realm and that is where
people started to perceive reality not
just through the immediate senses right
I mean people can see me people can hear
people are sitting down they can feel
the warmth etc but there is another
dimension to this which is dimension
which is beyond the sensorial and so the
first religions started to create this
attempt to to have a conversation so to
speak with these invisible forces that
seem to dominate their lives and be much
more powerful than they were right so
that is sort of the first impetus but
then you start around the sixth century
you know BCE so before the Common Era
you see this kind of explosion around
the world of different ways of dealing
with
problem so in India you had the Buddha
right so the Buddha started to
understand reality in a very different
way in which he perceived source of
suffering as being our attachment to
things and he wanted to empty you know
humans from this needs to have and to be
attached to things and he would say that
that is the root of all suffering and in
order to do that you have to kind of let
go and you would let go materially but
you also let go mentally through
meditation etc and then it's it's kind
of an amazing thing what happened then
because then in India in China you had
Lao Tzu and endow ISM and a little
letter just Confucianism and those
people were trying to make sense of
reality in different ways right this
invisible rearm out there which seems to
be so important but seems to be so out
of reach so to speak and then in Greece
you had the beginning of philosophy so
you had the pre-socratic philosophers
which sort of put not a very sharp but
they put an end to this notion that in
order to explain nature you have to
invoke God so you know instead of having
the Sun going around the sky because
there's a chariot of the god Helios that
carries the Sun around people started to
make rational attempt to make rational
explanations of nature and that is the
beginning of Western philosophy and that
I think is a crucial dividing point you
know from the before and the after words
because at that point you start to think
about what are the essential questions
about what makes up the world which
philosophers will call metaphysics you
know so we move in space we live in time
what is justice and those questions are
the questions are going to shape Western
civilization so very large extent both
philosophically and and scientifically
you know these guys are beginning to do
that and immediately I'm not going to go
through a whole survey of Greek thinking
here but one interesting point is an era
start all around 350 BCE
it reality into two parts you know below
the moon everything could change was
made of the four elements you know earth
water air fire and then above the moon
everything was made of a different
element the fifth essence ether of
quintessence and so there's a split of
two different realities you know below
where everything can change and decay
and this perfection up in the skies
right and and it took a long time for
people to move beyond this notion of
aerosol because the Catholic Church of
course embraced this whole idea and you
know the sky is immutable perfect our
becomes the realm of God right and so
only with Galileo and Kepler and Newton
in the 16th 17th century that things
really begin to change and we start to
look at reality in a more scientific way
I'm sure that at least some people who
are watching or listening to our
conversation now will get the sense that
well we really come so far we're much
more sophisticated now and and maybe we
have a much more objective view of
reality today than humans did in the
past but is that notion accurate in the
sense that it's always a subjective view
insofar as we we are in a sense impacted
by our own ability to impact and see
these things only from our perspective
we we sort of can't remove ourselves
from an inherently human understanding
of reality so is it is it right to say
we're so much more accurate today in
understanding reality than we were in
the past or is that really only a
relative idea that's an awesome question
because because it goes to how we make
sense of the world right I mean how we
create meaning with the information we
have of the world and and and people
tend to put science in a sort of a
pedestal you know say no scientific
approaches are the ones where we're
going to understand the truth and the
point is that you really can't say that
with science you know what science is
trying to do is to create a narrative
about the world and as you said quite
or acne you know this narrative depends
on us because we are the ones looking at
the world we are the ones experiencing
the world so everything that we do
depends on in a very very hard way on
the way we are wired up right and so
people that try to look for eternal
truths you know I did this again started
in ancient Greece with Plato and
Parmenides and people like that they
were trying to transcend this human look
of things and create what philosophers
like to call the view from nowhere that
is if you get you know to be true
essence of reality then there is no
human trace there there is only pure
truth and how do you do that well great
question right so Plato would say for
example that this truth is in our minds
on thoughts only right so you'd say that
the only perfect circle that exists is
the idea of the circle so when I say to
someone imagine a circle you know that
idea of the circles which is floating in
your head according to Plato is the only
perfect circle as long as soon as you
try to represent that you know draw the
circle or print the circle it's never
going to be perfect right and so on
these guys are basically trying to
separate the human from true knowledge
right and what we have seen and this is
something in my book the island of
knowledge I go on in in quality of
detail of detail that science does not
work that way
science is absolutely not about eternal
truths and so just to give you an
example of that which i think is a great
one which actually goes back to the
human component of things if you think
what is an electron right the particle
that composes the atom right that goes
around the nucleus well if you ask
JJ Thompson the guy who discovered the
electron in 1897 what's an electron he
would say it's some sort of small bit of
stuff with a negative charge right and
then if you go and you talk to more 1913
so not much long much after that
you said the Elector is the stuff that
transitions between levels in an atom
and if you go talk to Heisenberg in 1925
so just about 12 years after more he'll
give you a completely different
interpretation when the electron doesn't
even exist
it only exists as it interacts with
something else so you'd say what's in
reality is reality made of these
particles and Heisenberg would say we
can never answer that question then what
we know of nature depends very much on
the questions we are able to ask about
nature right and so that's exactly to
reinforce your point that the way we
construct knowledge about nature depends
very much on our ability our tools that
we use to formulate these questions
let's pick it up there we've been
speaking with Marcelo gleiser
theoretical physicist author and NPR
commentator he'll join us tomorrow to
continue our conversation and we'll get
into the idea of whether science can
tell us what is right and what is wrong
we're continuing our conversation today
with theoretical physicist author and
NPR commentator Marcelo gleiser his most
recent books are the island of knowledge
and the simple beauty of the unexpected
so yesterday we were speaking about the
nature of and our changing understanding
of reality and whether humans can have
sort of an objective understanding of
what we call reality
I'd like to dig in a little more
specifically into the ideas of right
versus wrong and whether science can
tell us or know whether there is some
objective right versus wrong
what sort of general concepts are
important to think about to really
understand even this conversation well
the first thing to understand is that
the way science works is by gathering
data about the world through
observations and experiments so we talk
about right and wrong you can always say
that things can be right within a
certain level of understanding so let me
give you an example to make that clear
if you think of Newton so Newton 1686
developed a theory of gravity which is
called
Universal theory of gravity with and
with that he explained the orbits of the
planets around the Sun he explained the
tides on earth he explained why the
earth is not a perfect sphere but it's
actually slightly is flat on the poles
because it's spinning a bunch of things
he explained the orbits of comets so
that theory in a sense is right because
it is being used to explain all all
sorts of phenomena that we are observing
and with very good precision so if
you're going to shoot a rocket to
Jupiter that's what you're going to use
you're going to use Newtonian gravity
right but if you push the theory beyond
its limits it starts to fall apart so if
you go to circumstances where gravity is
too strong so if you're close to a star
like the Sun if you want to be more
dramatic you feel close to the giant
black hole in the center of the Milky
Way which is a big
thing which weighs about three million
solar masses you know then if you try to
use Newton's theory to explain what's
going on next to these things you're
gonna make mistakes so the theory is
right within its range of validity right
but you need other theories to explain
things which push it beyond what it can
tell you and that's very important
because right or wrong depends on the
context so you have to contextualize the
question so if I pick up you know if I
pick up here on my desk a pencil on
right and I try and I drop it right I
can use even before Newton I can use
Galileo's freefall equation to tell you
how fast it's going to hit the table
right and that is correct but I could
never do that
in next a black hole or next to the Sun
because it wouldn't work right so I
think it's extremely important to
understand that so and this is this
simple stuff right I'm not even talking
about the theory of relativity where you
can have two people observing the same
phenomena and disagreeing with what
they're seeing just because they're
moving with respect to one another so
awesome or not-- i mean the context that
you referred to that sort of necessary
to frame what what what principles can
be used to analyze a situation that sort
of become very politicized for example
within the world of climate science and
you often hear from so-called climate
sceptics who will say listen the
scientific method has its flaws
so-called scientists have been wrong in
the past and thus it's really difficult
to know with any degree of certainty
what the objective truth is today about
the impact of humans on the on the
climate what is being sort of misused or
perverted about the scientific method by
that assertion from climate sceptics
that's a great question very timely I
actually so the point is that science
when you talk about this sort of science
complex climate science for example you
have to use that
stakes right you don't have a simple
little law like Newton's law that tells
you exactly where the moon is going to
be you know three months from now you
have to use statistical inference right
and so you can never be a hundred
percent sure of a prediction but you can
say that you have incredible compelling
evidence that if all the observations
and all the calculations of 99 percent
of the scientists are telling us that
the world is warming up and you look at
the emissions you know from 1850 on and
you see the big elbow picking up you
know about 20 30 years ago that this is
happening and that statistically the
odds are overwhelming that this is
happening because humans have been
putting stuff you know in the
environment for 200 years quite
intensely then I would say that we
should pay attention you can't say you
you can't use that theory the climate
change for example theory to say that
you know there's gonna be a hurricane in
the Bahamas on the 28th of September and
2017 that is not that kind of theory
that is Newton's theory of gravity and
orbits and stuff but it's a theory that
is going to say that if the trend
continues the probability of having you
know more dramatic weather-related
events is going to increase with a
certain rate and everything that we have
seen so far points to this correctness
of that theory so what people the
mistake that people make is first of all
to politicize a scientific question
right because climate change has
political implications and economic
implications of course but its first and
foremost a question about how about
science you know what can we say about
climate modeling and the measure and
measurements were making about the world
and I always say that even if you are a
climate skeptic as you say um we should
all be very aware that the planet is a
finite it has a finite environment you
know there is only so much a planet
can do you know it's a big planet but it
is only so much a planet can do so there
is no loss certainly there are issues
with what kind of approaches are gonna
take from the coal industry of course
you won't like this but there's no loss
in trying to protect as much as you can
the environment and our atmosphere so to
go a little bit from the sort of right
and wrong of a scientific assertion to
the concept of moral or ethical
correctness sam harris has written the
moral landscape there's been a lot
written about whether or not science
rather than religion in many cases can
tell us what is morally or ethically
right or wrong what are some important
considerations when we evaluate Sciences
ability to tell us objectively whether
something is ethical or unethical moral
or immoral that's a question that if
people are going to try to use cognitive
neuroscience you know to find out where
morality sits I think that's just not
going to go anywhere there is a question
where you really need not just science
but you need any the humanities as well
so I always say that science is actually
a moral what is what what has morality
is how you choose to apply the
scientific knowledge right so I actually
just wrote something on NPR about this a
week ago is the science know right from
wrong and and to make a long story short
I was talking about I was talking about
the issue of the atomic bomb right and
the fact that it was deployed in a
civilian population who made that choice
right well it turns out that the
scientists had a some an agreement with
the state and this relationship between
science and state is a very complex and
fragile one because scientists need the
state in order to fund their research
and the state means the scientists in
order to advance their defense agenda
right but at the end of the day
the decision on how to use the
scientific developments comes from the
people in power and as we know from
history those people in power are not
the scientists right they are the people
in this active branch of government
mostly military so so the point is the
only solution here according to me
anyways is you have to be very aware of
who are the leaders that you're choosing
and who you're choosing to work for so
perhaps at the individual level the
scientist has the choice of aligning him
or herself with the leadership that he
or she chooses or working with the
corporation that he or she chooses
within a certain limit because people
have to eat they have to get jobs but
the point is that the moral choices come
not with the use of the scientists of
the science by the scientists but how
you choose to give what you know to the
people they actually have the power to
use what you know do you where do you
fall on the idea that maybe the the
concept of morality or ethics does lend
itself more to some of the subjectivity
of the humanities but that science can
very definitively measure for example
well-being right and well-being could be
defined as you know life expectancy or
the number of people who would be saved
versus the number of people who might
perish if a certain medication research
program is put forward talk a little bit
about that I mean what can and can't
science measure in an objective way well
there is no question that there's the
feel-good thing but you know there are
bad things that can make you feel good
as well right so it's it's it's really
very subtle to say that science can be
used as a measure of wellness you know I
think because you can you can be a drug
addict you know and that's very bad but
if you take Harry and you're gonna feel
better you know
and and and you're gonna sell these
endorphins you know system and so you're
using science in the right context here
are you just fooling yourself because
it's you know you see the endorphins
there right so I would be very very
careful when people start to push
science into these sorts of realms
because this is really not i believe
what science is about you know science
is about constructing a narrative of the
natural world us included right so we
try to make sense of nature we try to
make sense of our place in nature we try
to understand human consciousness and
when you start to talk about the values
of choices that we make right and you
can say that for a psychopath killing
people will make him or her feel good
you know so if you're going to put an
fMRI on the head of a psychopath if
during the act a violent act you're
gonna see cannabinoids and you're going
to see endorphins flooding in and I'm
gonna say hey the measurements indicate
that this person is feeling good doing
this even though what he or she is doing
is profoundly wrong right
so I would be very very careful with
that sort of let's use science to
conquer in a sense parts of the
humanities which are kind of iffy
because the humanities tend to be iffy
you know and I'm speaking this as a
theoretical physicist you know I think
what we need is to understand the need
for a complementarity of different kinds
of knowledge as you know and the
scientific and the humanities they and
the social scientists they all have
something to say when the question is
the choices that we make about what is
right and what is wrong absolutely
fascinating we've been speaking with
Marcelo gleiser theoretical physicist
author NPR commentator his most recent
books are the island of knowledge and
the simple beauty of the unexpected
thanks so much for talking to us about
these issues
my pleasure David thank you so much for
having me